[Musique]
Luana se plaît être apaisiste et fille
de trapéziste en 2020 son grand rêve de
premier rôle dans une nouvelle création
du Cirque du Soleil a volé en éclat à
quelques jours d'entrer en scène la
pandémie a forcé la raie de tous les
spectacles et la presque totalité des
employés du cercle ont été condés
a été la fin de d'un rêve ça a été
l'écroulement de quelque chose ça a été
très dur à accepter trois ans plus tard
louana est revenu au cirque même si elle
avait d'autres projets en tête donc j'ai
pris la décision de de le faire pour pas
regretter puis les autres projets je
vais les je vais les faire après au ciel
social du Cirque du Soleil à Montréal
ils sont nombreux à être de retour il y
avait 1000 employés avant la crise il y
en a aujourd'hui
775 dont Chantal Tremblay qui en est à
sa 31ème année avec le Cirque alors moi
j'ai repris en 2021 on était juste
quelques-uns au cirque quand on a
commencé à continuer à parler du
spectacle écho et de la reprise donc ça
grossit on on revoit les gens après
avoir été au bord du gouffre le cercle
du Soleil a été racheté par ses
créanciers en 2020 l'entreprise compte
désormais 3600 employés partout sur la
planète et présente 38 spectacles si un
peu moins qu'avant mais toute proportion
gardée les revenus bruts de 2022 sont
supérieurs à ceux de 2019 la vente de
billets textraordinaire en 2022 on a
battu des records sur plusieurs marchés
dont Montréal un record de tous les
temps avec 270 000 spectateurs si la
reprise est bonne certains marchés sont
plus précaires que d'autres par exemple
la Floride ajouter à cela que le cirque
n'est pas à l'abri des aléas de
l'inflation et d'une possible récession
oui les coups de transport vont
augmenter donc on est on est on est en
attente de voir ce qui va ce qui va se
passer présentement on ne le sent pas je
dois le dire si le cercle du soleil a su
rebondir c'est en grande partie à cause
de son image de marque qui pensait
d'expert c'est vraiment à cause de la
force à cause de la force de la marque
[Musique]